كيف سيغير الذكاء الاصطناعي العالم في 20
30 هل سيقضي على الجنس البشري الحقيقه ان
البعض يؤيد هذه النظريه فما التقدم
المتسارع لذكاء الصناعي تنتشر توقعاته
متعدده عن الدور الذي ستلعبه هذه
التكنولوجيا في حياه البشر والشكل الذي
سيكون عليه العالم في السنوات المقبله ومن
ميزات هذه التكنولوجيا انها ستكون قادره
على الاعتناء بكبار السن او صنع الافلام
والتدريس ويليام هاوي كاتب سلسله الخيال
سايلو توقع ان يصبح ذكاء للصناعي قادرا
على انتاج افلام كامله في غضون يوم واحد
لكن على المقلب الاخر يمكن ان يقضي حتى
على الجنس البشري بحلول عام 2030 هكذا
يقول تحقيق لصحيفه ديلي ميل بريطانيه ومن
بين هؤلاء المتشائمين عالم الكمبيوتر
الامريكي لعازر يوت كوفسكي الذي راهن على
ان الجنس البشري سيقضى عليه تماما بحلول
الاول من ينا
ومن بين الخبراء البارزين الاخرين الذين
يقولون ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يدمر
الحضاره انه الملياردير ايلون ماسك
والعالم بريطاني ستيفن هوكينج لكن هؤلاء
لم يقصدوا الاشاره الى ان جميع البشر سيتم
القضاء عليهم بحلول عام 2030 في موازاه
ذلك يقترح خبراء ايضا ان ذكاء الاصطناعي
يمكن ان يعزز قيمه الاقتصاد العالمي
بمقدار
15.7 ترليون دولار بحلول عام 2030 تكثر
التنبؤات ايضا بان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن
ان يصل الى ذكاء شبيه بالانسان بحلول عام
2030 من بين اولئك الذين اطلقوا التحذير
مهندس جوجل السابق وهو عالم مستقبلي مشهور
يدعي بان التنبؤات تحقق معدل نجاح بنسبه
86%
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات